[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
peter king
nbc sports and his column of course
football morning in america
joining us on the program pete thanks
for joining us from a football
standpoint where do these allegations
against deshaun watson
impact his trade value
well dan i think it makes it very
difficult for
any team most likely between now and the
draft
it's going to make it very difficult for
any team to trade for them as long as
these charges are
in the air if you are the carolina
panthers
clearly interested in desean watson uh
and if you are the miami dolphins who
may be interested in desean watson and
the jets
same thing how do you make a trade for a
guy
who has uh numerous uh
sexual assault charges
uh uh i'm sorry allegations and that's
all they are now
allegations i don't know how you make
that trade now
uh with the allegations in the air
against deshaun watson
are the texans more likely to want to
deal him now
with what's going on or once is this is
resolved i think that is moot
if you don't have i don't dan i really
don't see how
a team can make a trade i don't i don't
see a trade being made on this
until we have some knowledge
of what exactly happened in these cases
in these alleged cases so
the texans could want to trade him more
today than they did
a week ago but i don't think it really
matters unless you've got
there i mean i suppose i suppose
there could be a team out there whose
owner and or general manager
and or coach could say we'll do this
regardless of uh what the allegations
are
i just can't believe in these in this
day and time yeah that anybody
possibly could do that yeah i agree with
you
and if i'm negotiating or had been
negotiating or trying to negotiate
if if i'm coming back now my offer is
not going to be the same
i'm sure for desean watson but now the
nfl is involved peter
to what degree i don't know but now all
of a sudden
if that's on you know the the
commissioner's desk
you know that could take weeks it could
take months
before they of course get around to this
i you know in the long run
and i'm not saying that uh that
i i don't we don't know any of the
details
dan but if
if there were some offers to try to
settle these cases
uh i mean at at this point right now the
one thing i
am wondering is was there
some thought on the part of desean
watson
and uh you know his legal counsel
to seriously consider trying to settle
these cases beforehand so basically this
would
go away and and those are the things we
simply
don't know desean watson has come out
and very strongly said i have never
uh taken liberties such liberties with
women
uh and so we'll see what what the truth
is coming forward
i was curious about this mentioned it a
couple of days ago with
russell wilson and uh that offer that
was made by the chicago bears
seattle didn't counter the bears offer
normally if you go in and
you know make a bid on a house the owner
usually the seller comes back and says
no i want this why did seattle even
engage if they weren't even going to
counter
the chicago bear's offer professional
courtesy
that's my guess because
dan listen suppose i i don't
i said this two weeks ago in my column
and got roundly
what an idiot you are for for saying
this
but the chicago bears never
ever ever ever had
the ammunition to go get russell wilson
it
they just didn't everybody said well
wait a second three ones
well this year's one is number 20
and if russell wilson is going to the
chicago bears
they probably are going to be just as
good or
better than they were in 2020.
if that's the case what are you trading
the 20th pick in the draft this year
the 25th pick in the draft next year the
23rd pick in the draft
two years from now and in addition
john schneider made a trade with the new
york jets
almost a year ago or eight months ago
for jamal adams
and i firmly believe that one of the
reasons that he paid a heavy
price for jamal adams is that he knew
that in 2021 the draft was going to be
shrouded
in mystery all these players who didn't
play
in 2020 or you know because they opted
out at her teams didn't play much or
i mean trey lance played division one
double a and has
one game in the last 400 days so i mean
or 430 days something like that
so how do you how do you how do you
figure out who these players are
right now and so i do think
that john schneider uh why not listen
maybe there's something that he totally
does not expect
what if he gets offered three ones
three twos three threes or so you know
and
and khalil mack does he listen i would
say probably
but three ones that are all in the 20s
for a franchise quarterback who says
he's playing well into his 40s
it's just not in even remotely
inequitable trade
how do you think this plays out with
pete carroll and russell wilson
i believe that at some point barring
some team coming to make an incredible
offer
say the miami dolphins tuatanga valoa
the third pick in the draft and a couple
more very high picks
then i think john schneider would have
to listen to it
now he would have to you'd also have to
figure that
you know he would have some regard for
for tuatangavalo and i don't know if he
does or not
but assuming that he doesn't get traded
pete carroll will put on his don't worry
be happy
coat and meet with russell wilson and
probably sometime in may and they'll all
live happily ever after even though they
really won't
dan how did pete carroll get along
with marshawn lynch for so long when
marshawn lynch was making his life hell
how did he do that he turns the other
cheek
and he thinks to himself if you know as
long as i don't pay attention to it
acknowledge it all that stuff
it's it it can't hurt me whether it did
or not
i don't know but in my opinion
russell wilson is not going to be
incendiary
when he gets inside the team this year
that's just not who he is
he's peter king his must-read column
every monday morning
is football morning in america the
arizona cardinals
got a little older did they get better
i think that's a fantastic question i
mean
you know i just finished i started
writing a little bit of my column
yesterday and i just finished writing a
section about the arizona cardinals
and you know my my thought about aj
green
is not that the arizona cardinals
acquired a great wide receiver
from watching him play in recent years
they've acquired
a guy who's been hurt a lot and been
indifferent
and i i mean will he suddenly be reborn
outside of what he may have considered a
horrible place to play in cincinnati
i don't know we'll see but i have not
seen one ever one bit of evidence that
aj green
can be great again maybe he can and if
he can
it sure isn't based on what we've seen
the last two or three years
one of which he missed entirely with a
knee injury
and so i don't know about that now jj
watt obviously
i think he definitely has some
some football left that
could be very very good especially
playing
opposite or or with chandler jones
because he never had
a guy who was as good as chandler jones
uh
in houston now again we all know
how much time jj watt has missed and so
you know we'll see but right now you
know i looked it up dan
jj watt matt prater aj green
were in the 2013 pro bowl
and now they're all they're going to be
32 33 and 37
this year prater being 37. so
you know they've they've won the
the famous free agency the arizona
cardinals have
i i don't know if they're significantly
better now
rodney hudson now that is a that's a
fantastic
addition because he's still in his prime
and
they'll need a couple more of those guys
to be in theirs
what do you think the jets are going to
do at number two take zach wilson
i just i can't imagine i didn't think
they were going to trade for deshaun
watson anyway
you know those in the league who know
joe douglas well know
that he loves the draft and he loves
building through the draft
so i've always believed that they're
gonna sit there
and take the next best quarterback after
trevor lawrence now
i think it's zach wilson maybe he's in
love with justin fields
i don't know uh but i think they're
gonna take a quarterback at number two
and sam darnold's future is where
you know i've got to think that he'll
get traded for
some pick between 40 and 75
you know on close to the draft
uh because you know look sam darnold
could well be a one-year addition for
some team
all along i've been saying that the
49ers should trade
the 43rd pick in the draft for him and i
still don't think it would be a bad idea
but the problem
the only problem with trading the 43rd
pick in the draft
is in essence you're trading for a guy
who
probably is going to be your backup
quarterback the whole year and then is
going to be a free agent
because clearly you aren't going to
exercise his 50 year option
so it's a tough thing to trade the 43rd
pick
for a one year trial even though sam
darnold would make your team
better for this particular year
and look we still don't know absolutely
with certainty that jimmy garoppolo is
going to be the 49ers quarterback this
year we think he's going to be it
but we don't know that for sure pete
have a great weekend i looked at your
bracket
uh do you know what you're doing with
your uh no
i don't have any idea i don't i dan i
don't watch college basketball
todd fritz me being a good soldier todd
fritz asked me to send him a bracket
and so i did and so i got florida state
going a long way
and i got the bobcats winning a game and
blah blah blah
you got arkansas gonzaga you got
illinois winning it all
yeah i do okay is that possible yes yeah
it is
well i gotta tell you pete thammel told
me who to pick
because i i texted him he's the yahoo
sports guy he's a good friend of mine
and i said who should i pick and so he
told me a couple of teams that he
thought were good and
told me some teams that weren't good so
i don't know i filled it out all right
good to talk to you as always pete have
a great weekend thanks for joining us
hey thank you dan you have a good one
too
that's peter king nbcsports.com
columnist football morning in america